we have this from Fox News Stanford
releases guide to eliminate harmful
language cautions against calling U.S
citizens American Stanford's index says
it's a goal its goal is to eliminate
many forms of harmful language so you
said maybe the fervents or the Zeal that
the right could tap into his americanism
there's America first but uh they're
preempting you they're already coming
out and saying it's harmful language to
do so which is a good sign that this is
actually the direction we need to be
going to see the left is smarter this
way because the the things that they've
replaced religion with they are actually
Tools in which they gain more power
whether that's feminism radical leftism
wokism you name it these are actually
tools that not only replace religion
climatism they simultaneously further
State Control it's actually the opposite
with the right what are we trying to get
people passionate about small government
uh we're religion families being less uh
subservient to the government it's funny
we're actually shooting ourselves in the
foot by trying to breed this I guess
fervance in dependency and otherwise
living happily lives that don't require
us to become Servants of this state the
leftist is smart in that way they
understand that if you want people to
essentially need you you need to not
only make it their politics but also
their personal identity and religion as
well and I think that with the absence
of religion I I think a lot of people
replaced you know the Christian church
or the uh you know Islam with
specifically the state and they worship
fauci they have candles of them they
have you know altars of them so so I I
think at the end of the day the
Republicans need to be called out
because if they're good at anything it's
capitulating and surrendering Uh Kevin
McCarthy right now I don't see reigning
in the FBI he has an opportunity to do
so he's not but Trump is still endorsing
him Kevin McCarthy called for Donald
Trump to resign as president of the
United States why are you endorsing him
and telling your local Congress members
not to fight his appointment this is
absolutely crazy
becomes the
institutionalists of politics said that
the number one priority 34 Republicans
is actually to ensure that Ukraine gets
those missiles and is able to defeat
Russia which says zelinski is coming to
the United States Capitol to address the
United States yes as there's going to be
a big Bill negotiating 46 billion
dollars that's going to be additionally
possibly sent to Ukraine to prolong this
larger proxy war which is bringing us
closer to the brink of nuclear Holocaust
you mentioned earlier in the show Luke
about how they're taking your tax money
and I was going to say something then
but I'll say it now too about this this
all the money that's sending to Ukraine
it's modern monetary policy they're not
they're not really taking your tax money
they're just Mass printing your money
and extracting through inflation from
your savings so whether whether it's
paid or not they're finding a way to gut
the the American middle class so they
can fund their Wars they could do
whatever they want there there there's
no oversight in that well it's a
transfer of wealth from from everybody
else to the super rich it's socialism
for the super rich that we're seeing
right now with specifically the
military-industrial complex getting
their way we're running out of missiles
there's other countries that are running
out of bullets especially Germany there
was a news report saying Germany has
given out so much
Okay so
which is the country
which is the major developed country
that lobbied against the EU ban on
Russian oil imports anyone know the
answer to this
it's the United States
the Biden White House was the major
nation that was begging the EU as we now
head into the end of the year the
Russian the EU ban on Russian oil
imports goes into effect now why is that
it's actually there's a long reason why
we've gone to war on our own fossil
fuels industry that actually worries
about the consequences for Global you
know let's just say oil and gas markets
if that EU ban actually goes in
especially when Chinese coronavirus
related restrictions are being lifted
there's a supply demand shock but but I
want to point out the irony of this we
are with one hand sending 40 to 45
billion dollars or more to Ukraine to
fight against Vladimir Putin while with
the other hand are the leading nation
that calls for
overriding the EU pen on Russian royal
Imports which in turn finances Putin's
war machine to actually invade Ukraine
so that's why the whole thing is
actually even a farce the idea of
getting into should we or should we not
support Ukraine okay I think we're over
allocated to Ukraine we need to focus
our military's energy on the one
geopolitical threat that matters the
United States which is China but that's
a policy Point here's even if you were
committed to the pro-ukraine cause at
all cost
even the effectuation of that is itself
frustrated by the fact that if you
wanted to do it you would be starving
Putin's Army yet Biden is the one who's
actually arguing for allowing Putin's
Putin finances War Machine by selling
oil and gas to Europe which is actually
the laughable farce of the whole thing
and I believe it was also fertilizer as
well I think uh someone could factor to
check me as well that they were also
buying a bunch of fertilizer from them
and financing them that way why is why
are we doing it why are we why are we
playing both sides on the issue
so it's because it's a cell form of
self-loathing actually I don't mean this
I don't mean this just in a culturally
superficial sense I mean in a
deep-seated sense we live in a moment of
Western and particularly American
self-loathing and it'll just since I
bend up the oil and gas example and I
could give you six fears of life where
this is true but let's talk about the
oil and gas examples I just brought it
up all right why is it that now we're
talking about other religions let's talk
about climatism why is it that the
members of the Church of climate the
climate activists are
so averse to the United States producing
oil and gas but are perfectly fine with
global markets that allow the likes of
petrochina and also many Russian oil and
gas producers to pick up the slack
ironically oil and gas producers over
there who have actually methane leakage
that is far worse than in the Permian
Basin of Texas and by the way even if
you subscribe to The Climate religion
methane is 80 times worse for for the
global atmosphere and global warming
than is every unit of carbon dioxide why
are they okay with that the answer to
that question is the same as the answer
to the question of why those are the
exact same people who are also opposed
to the development of nuclear energy in
the United States which would actually
be the single most efficient form of
carbon-free energy production known to
mankind what's going on the problem
isn't that let's say nuclear energy
wouldn't be good enough at solving the
alleged climate crisis it is that it
would be too good at solving the alleged
climate crisis which in turn is really
just a vehicle for effectuating the
agenda of global Equity so you want to
the answer question why Tim it is
because this is a a moment of global
redistribution back from the West to the
other side of the world including Russia
and China and everything in our
self-loathing is flogging ourselves for
the sins the perceived sins of the last
century to say that we'll give the 45
billion to Ukraine but we also want to
make sure that actually we shift oil
production to places like Russia and we
don't ban the Russia EU ban and Russian
oil imports because it's really just a
form of self-loathing at its core that's
what we're seeing on display and just
really quick that's because war is a
racket and throughout history there have
been powerful people supporting both
sides that's been well documented but
with the United States supporting
Ukraine right now and giving them
billions of and billions and billions of
dollars there's this misnomer that it's
oh Ukraine's just doing whatever Ukraine
wants it's a Ukrainian policy but we not
only incentivize the continuation of
this proxy war which is extremely
dangerous but also at the same time we
have to remember when zielinski actually
reached the peace deal with Putin they
had a date where they were supposed to
come together sit down meet and
negotiate and sign up peace deal we had
Western Powers come to Ukraine
specifically the UK UK prime minister
came there and said no you're not
signing this peace deal and Ukraine has
been the one backing away from peace
continuing this war endangering everyone
which is absolutely insane as this war
is also hurting the poorest people in
the world not just the people of Ukraine
but this has global economic impacts
that's going to wreck our whole entire
Financial system in ways that we have
never seen before and I think it's right
to say that there for a lot of the
activist class there is absolutely
self-flothing involved especially when
it comes to the climate change agenda
but when it comes to Ukraine
specifically and yes even climate change
I also don't want to underestimate how
how many people are actually getting
rich off of this how many people are
getting rich off of the subsidies to
Green energy that no you're right it's
not as efficient as nuclear places like
France like we already know that if we
were to build new nuclear plants in the
U.S which I don't think has been done
since the 70s they would be even safer
than the ones that exist now but we
haven't been able to do it because of
fear-mongering same with Ukraine it's
bad for America it is very good very
lucrative for the military and
industrial complex zielinski actually
spoke at one of these conferences for I
guess big war they're not even trying to
hide it at this whole point it's so
blatant The Exchange is happening there
you mentioned with climate change and it
reminded me of this viral video that
people keep sharing where it's this guy
saying if if all of this stuff was true
in every prospectus for a a for a
nuclear study oh for construction it
would say you know the condos in Miami
Beach in 30 to 40 years your investment
will be zero as the water rises and
makes us uninhabitable but not a single
Bank not a single person has ever
brought that up so why are they still
investing in why are they still buying
30 to 40 Euro you know Properties or
loans if the water is going to rise and
wipe out this whole area no they they're
living in the beachfront property so
that other people can't do it and you
know so they're safe and and they are
willing to take the bullet for all of us
by living bearing that cross exactly
brave men lots of beachfront property as
well Barack Obama lots of beaches
we want to thank the these guys for
their sacrifice really means a lot to us
thank you it's the meme of uh you know
from The Simpsons of the person jumping
in front of the bullet for Apu or
whatever you know they're they're trying
yeah I love that you're part of Bill
Gates story he was um so he was my
College commencement speaker and you
know what I was looking at that time he
was the world's richest man
I didn't come from a lot of money I was
unapologetically ready to make some
after I got out of college moving to New
York working at a hedge fund I was like
all right let's let's figure out how one
creates the level of of wealth that Bill
Gates has the only thing he would talk
about is how to the whole speech it was
it was one of the more disappointing
speeches I heard my life I remember it I
was I met him on stage afterwards
it was all about how to give back what
one has gained and I love and ever since
that moment I was like look the
expression of even giving back
doesn't make sense to me because it
assumes that one took in the first place
actually I think he's done a lot of
taking ever since he started the giving
back project but making the PC was not
actually the one thing that he took in
the first place that was actually the
one thing that he created and I think it
was right around then I mean this was
this is as I graduated from college in
2007 then came the 2008 financial crisis
right after right after I graduated and
that was when this period of of
apologism began and that's why I think
americanism for a different reason too
is part of the solution is once we stop
having to apologize for the successes of
the modern West for the successes of
modern America we can have a model that
the rest of the world can follow to lift
themselves up but I I could I could
almost pick 99 of the things that the
four of us at this table would find
disappointing about the direction of
modern American culture and pin it to
this culture of apologism for our own
success and I think that that's why the
answer can't be us going one at a time
playing whack-a-mole trying to send that
mole back into its into its rabbit hole
but to instead fill that void with the
sense of revive Pride an Unapologetic
pursuit of excellence and that is what
it means to be American I am not going
to apologize for it through some climate
religion that causes me to adopt an
emissions cap through some racial Equity
system that causes me to use a racial
quota system to hand out Goods According
to some Metric other than Merit no I'm
going to do this in the same way that
got us 250 years into this experiment I
am not going to apologize for it if
we're going to make another 250 years
from now that's how we're going to do it
and I think we need to get I wouldn't
use the word religious but I think we
need to get fanatical behind the idea
that set the whole experiment into
motion rather than hanging on and you
might disagree with me here but rather
than hanging on the thin uh siren song
of proceduralism right liberals abandon
liberalism because because they were
smart there's something about the idea
of just hey it's just about Free Speech
free markets hey individual autonomy
those are just procedural Norms that
don't satisfy the more base human hunger
in a way that wokeism or climatism or
covetism does and I think that I think
that the what the right needs to wake up
to in this country is that just falling
back on the slogans of liberalism
proceduralism is not going to be enough
we need our own affirmative values I
think Excellence the Unapologetic
pursuit of Excellence what I was just
talking about probably belongs on that
list maybe somebody else says it's
something else but we need we need an
affirmative
content that people can actually get
fanatical about but it's actually
content that's actually far more Rich
than workers on the other side thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time